he's a seven-time pro bowl quarterback
he is the reigning walter payton man of
the year and we say hello on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line prior to
his monday night game against the
washington football team we say hello to
seattle seahawks quarterback russell
wilson how you doing russell
rich man uh it's always a pleasure man
how you been i am doing well i'm doing
better for talking to you so let's talk
about your your current situation uh
sitting there at three and seven i
looked it up russ uh because you know i
get bored but i'm also a lead pipe
building professional the last time you
were four games under 500 was freshman
year of college for you
um
this has not been a feeling that you've
been used to what is it like for you to
be in your current
state right now russell well you know
what it is it's an opportunity
you know it's adversity and uh adversity
fades if you if you have the right
mentality if you can be neutral with it
and understand that it's a process and
understand that you take every day and
you try to still find ways to get better
and despite all the noise despite all
the mess and this and that you stay
focused on the task and the mission and
the mission is one game one game a week
one day at a time one snap at a time
and uh you know and we got seven games
left and uh if anybody can come back we
believe we can come back and win all
seven so
that's what we feel that's what we
believe that's our mentality that's what
we've been saying and that's what we're
gonna have to do yeah and when you were
four games under 500 as a freshman you
won the next four in a row so that did
happen so these things you have you have
had these experiences before and i know
again uh talking about injuries is not
something it comes across sound like an
excuse or what have you but is your hand
the same right now
russ no i feel great you know i've been
um
you know obviously it's supposed to be
eight weeks or more probably most likely
and we've been we've been pushing to get
back out there
and uh we accelerated the whole process
we did it before and you know and so you
know i feel great you know um
it's already you know i've been i've
been you know throwing it around you
know i've been throwing some deep ones
and this and that so i feel you know i
was about launched that deep on last
week the dk
and all that and we've had some good
stuff tyler's been looking great so i
think for me uh it's just us catching
our groove it's just you know it's
getting that mojo and all of us together
and making it happen and just you know
not having any mistakes and just staying
on course and i think that if we stay on
course we can do all things and so
uh you know i you know when we catch
fire everybody better watch out so
that's what we believe russell wilson
here uh on the rich eisen show and so um
what about your your the offense and
your say in it i was such a conversation
obviously back in the spring and we're
all now in the nfl media to be honest
revisiting those conversations based on
your record right now where where does
that stand about you and shane waldron
and the offense that has not been for
the lack of better phrase cooking last
couple of weeks i think i think you know
shane's great i think he's got
tremendous knowledge i think he knows
exactly what what he's doing and we you
know we know what we need to do it's
also on us players to execute and make
sure that we do everything that we're
supposed to do and and and uh and
coaches as well and everybody being
together all this together and so
offense defense special teams we've you
know we've had a battle all year it's
been tough games and tough moments um
you know we we started off you know
relatively good we lost some tough games
late
this and that and so
and then we kind of had a tough stretch
there um you know and then you know with
you know me getting hurt and then the
battle
coming back and so we you know we have
to answer you know we have to answer the
bell and and go and and you know it's
it's it's not a complicated thing you
know we've won a lot of games before and
we can do it again and so uh all that
belief and all that confidence is there
you know this is a team that's um
you know that that won the nfc west last
year and uh you know we we've been able
to win before um it's not like we
haven't won you know before in the past
or anything like that you know we've won
for many years so we know what it's like
to win um you know and and and uh you
know it's a little bit unfamiliar space
but at the same time that's where you
grow the most if you're willing to to
receive it and take it and understand
how you grow and so
you know for me as a leader i i'm i'm on
one track mind i'm on one track mine
just of getting us back on track and
making sure that you know this game is
the only game this is it you know this
is it and every week from here on out
this is it when no matter what happens
you know you you you you leave it all on
the field you know for your teammates
you leave it all in the field for your
for your family you leave it all on the
field for our fans and you know that's
that's what i know i'm going to do i'm
going to play as as hard as i can every
play no matter what and do it give
everything i have every day every time
here early and late at night you know
give everything i have that's that's
that's always been the case and that's
never going to change yeah eyes on
youtube and everything that's what
you're saying like eyes on you not just
on the field but in the facility right
like you're that you're that guy walking
you're bouncing around sounds you know
like your coach is one of the most
positive people i've ever been around
too and you kind of be very honest with
you sound like him right now russ you
know you do sound like you know like
that this is
this is the only way out is for you to
be kind of bouncing off the walls and
telling everybody attaboy you know what
i mean right now that's what that sounds
like yeah i don't know if it's got to be
overly positive i think we got to be
definitely neutral though you know
there's not not much you know
there's things to be positive about but
it is it's tough to be positive when
you're when you're three and seven right
you know so what we have to be is
neutral we can't be negative though
because negativity works 100 of the time
so what we're going to focus on is being
neutral and having the right language
and what is championship language what
does it sound like what is what is
getting back on track lean what do we
have to do and then just go do it you
know
we can't be emotional with this you know
we you know the absence of emotion um
absence of being emotional and just you
know playing with great passion playing
with great energy playing with what we
know how to do and playing with great
effort and if we can do that then we
give ourselves a great chance
who do you lean on in times like this
right now who do you talk to like who's
on the who who's at the russell wilson
round table here for you um yeah i mean
i think number one person i talk to is
myself in my head
you know self-talk is everything so you
know what you tell yourself what you
what the absence of negativity you know
to push things away to not listen to it
to just stay focused on the task at hand
that's the number one person
and i think that's key i think that's
key um
and so uh that's that's really crucial i
think you know i you know i talked to
tim grover i talked to i talked to um a
few others as well um and so you know i
stay focused on my task you know i talk
to our teammates as well you know
speaking life into those situations
russell wilson here on the rich eisens
show do you ever catch yourself look
down and see that symbol on your on your
uh
on your uh jersey that walter payton man
in the ear symbol and just go that's
that's pretty damn cool man like did you
ever have a moment like that during the
season
yeah you know um
first game of the year you know we we
went to indy played in epic cults and to
be in that stadium was such a great
tradition obviously peyton playing there
and some amazing other amazing players
and you know dwight freeman's of the
world and you know and some other great
players along the way
you know i think about um
you know just
i think about how much my dad you know
loved walter payton you know he was his
favorite player and uh when i think
about you know how much he talked about
him and and everything else i know my
grandfather talking about him all the
time too as well and so you know for me
to just to be uh to be able to win
walter peyton manning the year award was
a blessing you know and it's been a
crazy year just in general with covid
and life in general and just everything
going on in people's worlds and
everything else and just
over the past year and a half you know
two years to be able to make a
difference for people is
you know what i believe god put me on
this earth to do obviously to win games
and throw touchdowns and make a
difference and use that platform for
good and um i think that what's been a
blessing is for me and sierra with our
foundation you foundation you know to be
able to use that for good and to help
people and help the youth and to help
with childhood cancer and to be able to
build a school like why not you academy
and to be able to you know help with you
know um with people in hunger you know
and just it's been an amazing journey
and so you know you have to step up to
the plate and and much as given much is
required and i'm just grateful that i
get to do what i get to do and i love it
so it's uh
it's it's fun giving back but it's also
fun playing ball you know i love this
game so much and that's why i tried to
do everything i could to get back on the
field because you know you you love this
game and you want to give it all your
all and our days are numbered you know
what i mean in life you know not just
not just in our careers but in life you
never know you know especially as we've
gone through this covet thing and so
many other things and i've seen my dad
pass away i've seen others go
come and go it's one of those things
that every day if we have the right
mindset and we have the right attitude
if we have the right love in our heart
and to be able to serve and give back
that's what we're here to do and to make
a difference in people's worlds and my
dad used to say one thing the last thing
i'll leave you with with this thought is
you know my dad used to say you know
son you know on the day you're born it's
not the day you die that people are
going to measure you it's it's the hash
mark in between but you're that that's
that's where your significant
significance comes from right and so i
think about that hash mark you know and
so for me you know i want to make sure
that that little dash a little hash mark
in between the day i was born and the
dad died that i i can make a difference
in people's worlds and
i'm blessed i get to do with sierra i'm
the best i get to deal with a great
organization and people as well
um and teammates and just it's fun you
know i you know it's it's
i'm one of 32 men in the world out of
eight billion people come on i've done
getting better
that's a great way to put it you had a
you're having a heck of a hash mark to
say the least and then you know the
monday nighter for you it's in a spot
where your first career playoff game
took place in your first career playoff
win
as well i'm sure that's not going to be
lost on you as you get your journey back
here uh in 2021 this coming monday right
exactly right you know it's uh lights
will be out you know they'll be on and
and uh you know it's a place that's
familiar with you know to me you know
played there before you know i grew up
in richmond you know about you know an
hour and a half two hours away from
there um you know and so a lot of great
tradition there and things you know that
stadium players and all that so to go
there and and to to step on that field
it's gonna be it's gonna be a great
night and i'm excited um
it's uh we gotta get back on track we're
gonna play a really good football team
they're playing great football right now
and so i've got a lot of respect for
coach rivera too he's amazing coach an
amazing man so um you know when you
think about you talking about somebody
who's who's beating the odds that man's
beating the odds in every way so you
know hopefully uh you know we can step
up to the challenge and play a great
football game and come home
you're the man russell wilson great chat
with you sir see you on monday night i
always uh appreciate our chats right
here thanks again yeah man it's a
blessing thank you rich always always a
pleasure man i'll [ __ ] you soon back at
that's russell wilson right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here